well this team created not only the
product strategy but as also the
manufacturing plan and also the
production plan and also the business
plan review process so they've had
wonderful success they've been it's been
served everybody well and I think mark
is gonna continue those major processes
going forward do you think marks gonna
do something different different from
what you did I mean you came here and it
was kind of a revolution and now the
best thing for him to do I'm sure in the
eyes of the board would just be to
continue your your administration but
does he have his own changes to make or
well marking the entire team as we've
talked about created the process that
created this strategy and we're just
getting started we're serving all the
markets around the world with his
complete family of best-in-class
vehicles
we're restructuring Europe we're gonna
be profitable that it next year u.s. is
doing well the fastest growing brand in
Asia Pacific led by India and China so
there's lots of opportunity for us to
continually profitably grow this great
corporation and you say we are just
getting started even though the end of
the month is officially yes yeah I did
say we I have I have a few more days to
be part of the week yeah but how many
more days I mean you still have a
sizable position in this company I
assume that you're gonna be coming back
to Dearborn once in a while I think I'll
maintain many of the great relationships
I have and I have fallen in love with
for that it's a great company and it's
so important on what it does for the
economy and energy independence and
security environmental sustainability so
I'm gonna stay close to afford going
forward Mark's gonna be able to call you
if he ever needs deal mark would like to
call me and I said absolutely anytime
what will you do after this month is
over I mean I heard you say you haven't
given a lot of thought to it so I'm
guessing you haven't made a decision
I really haven't spent very much time on
it because the focus that I've wanted to
have is on this orderly transition not
only at the leadership team but also of
the strategy and also the management
system so I've had the fortune to go all
around the world visit all of our
operations all of our fantastic
employees the dealers and suppliers and
thank them congratulate them and wish
them the very best and share with them
that I have all the confidence in the
world that
Ford is gonna be fantastic going forward
and they are part of something very very
special and wish them the very best it
strikes me that you know the the
popularity of the business plan review
and the way you deal with any kind of
crisis that pops up that your focus on
the succession plan has been a problem
for so many other companies
I remember when Steve Ballmer said he'd
asked you for some advice for Microsoft
you could easily have a very lucrative
practice advising other other leaders
well possibility well I'm really looking
forward to what what I might do I know
that I love to serve I know that the
world has lots of opportunity for
service but right now I've been focused
on this orderly transition at Ford and I
look really forward math to where the
future might bring and maybe even get a
chance to talk to you every once a while
will you take a couple weeks off will
you well I'll place - I think what I'm I
think what I'd like to do is call you on
July 2nd and tell you what I'm thinking
about and I'm probably gonna call you
from the Starbucks excellent so you call
me on July 2nd call you a sec promise